now let's turn to the radical socialists
2020 dumpster fire which is the
Democratic Party you have fake News CNN
programming well it's usually pretty bad
they have a hard time getting a million
people even in one given hour that's
pretty bad for a big cable channel last
night's debate well it took the failure
to a whole new level like a train wreck
sad hard to look away from in case you
were one of the few hundred million
Americans who didn't tune in here is a
small sample of the things that you
might have missed we can no longer allow
a white nationalist to be in the White
House I can talk to those white women in
the suburbs that voted for Trump and
explained to them what white privilege
actually is that when their son is
walking down a street with a bag of M&Ms
in his pocket wearing the hoodie his
whiteness is what protects them from not
being shocked we need to do everything
we can to start moving the climate in
the right direction but we also need to
start moving our people to higher ground
would there be any place for fossil
fuels including coal and fracking in a
Biden administration no we would we work
it out we would make sure its eliminated
so the first thing that I'm gonna do
when I'm president is I'm going to
Clorox the Oval Office
we lost the state of Michigan because
everybody from Republicans to Russians
were targeting the suppression of
african-american voters that's only tip
of the eye tip of the debate what
happened here now oddly enough what you
didn't hear during tonight's five hours
of debates on fake news CNN was the name
Robert Muller not a single time now look
this is the same network that for over
two years every second minute hour of
every day non-stop breathless hysterical
coverage Muller speculation including
yes coverage yeah every day not one word
about Muller the special counsel at
holding these debates
maybe that's because a new democratic
Paul and of course the media's in the
Democratic camp they're just the
extension of the press office it shows
support for impeaching President Trump
tanking after Muller's disastrous report
and hearing and these debates were
pretty much proof the Russia hoax Muller
that issues dead gone and buried we told
you about that along
time ago but let's not lose sight of a
very important fact that was confirmed
in last night's debate there are no
moderates running in the Democratic
Party there just aren't it's radical and
even more radical renew deal Medicare
for all maybe no health care choices but
free health care for illegal immigrants
candidates on stage have big plans for
all of your hard earned money this is a
new radical extreme socialist Democratic
Party and without oil and gas the
lifeblood of our economy well in a
matter of weeks the American Dream will
collapse as a matter of fact last night
proved even President Obama as bad as he
was as president is too moderate for
this new scary crop of candidates now
let's be clear the left-wing media mob
doesn't care when Democrats when they
push their baseless conspiracy theories
or promote their wild socialist policies
or pal around with bigots and they don't
seem to care about virulent
anti-semitism but criticizing Obama I
used to be strictly prohibited take a
look is it a smart strategy to attack
the Obama administration I watch all
night long in disbelief in disbelief
fully as nearly every one of them on
that stage went after Joe Biden's slash
Barack Obama
insane Ron I just don't fundamentally
get the strategy of going after the most
popular Democratic president in modern
memory back off of Obama in his legacy
there are other ways you can go at Joe
Biden without taking out Barack Obama
I'm wondering why people who want votes
from Democrats spent all last night
trashing Barack Obama in trying to go
after the front-runner Joe Biden they
would even sacrifice trying to throw
Barack Obama in front of the bus which
does not show real stability and
self-confidence it really shows
desperation